il s'agit d'une nouvelle forme de
location de voiture la voiture en libre
service dans la ville 150 voitures
seront répartis elles s'ouvriront tout
avec le même type de clé supposer que
vous avez une de ses clés en poche
en sortant de chez vous vous trouvez une
des voitures le long du trottoir vous
vous installer au volant et vous
démarrez arrivés à destination vous
laisser la voiture sur place
une autre personne qui possède également
la clé utilisera à son tour la voiture
et ainsi de suite
pour posséder la clé il suffit de
souscrire un abonnement pour mettre la
voiture en route il faut donc la clé il
faut aussi un jeton vous le placez dans
un boîtier prévu à cet effet et vous
pouvez ainsi roulé pendant un certains
nombre de kilomètres à chaque parcours
le jeton et rogner selon un procédé
électronique
quand nous avons donné la voiture vous
le récupérer il servira encore plus ou
moins en fonction de son usure lorsqu'il
est totalement utilisé vous reprenez un
jeton dans un distributeur automatique
le prix de revient est environ de 50
centimes par kilo l'accueil des
habitants de mon payer est loin d'être
défavorable les avantages du système est
évident s'il est bien appliqué il y aura
moins de voitures dans les rues
d'autre part plus de problèmes d'essence
de vignettes ou d'assurance tous ces
frais sont compris dans l'achat du jeu
ton en cas de panne la solution est
encore plus simple il suffit de
reprendre sa clé son jeton et de changer
de voiture
un signal électronique préviendra une
permanence centrale de l'incident et de
l'emplacement du véhicule
un dernier avantage il n'est pas
négligeable plus de problème de
stationnement dans la ville
quelques 300 places sont spécialement
réservés
si l'expérience est concluante ce
système sera étendu dans d'autres villes
ans
[Musique]